we got an amazing crowd here this
evening and oh you got that right I love
this crowd especially the ladies huh so
excuse me who are you what's going on
I'm Lou grub insky a New York City
construction worker
okay well Lou we don't really need you
out here harassing the women in our
audience hey I take offense to that
Conan these days every construction
worker in New York City is required to
go through hours of sensitivity training
and psychotherapy we're all totally woke
now Kevin Lee get this faint you're
saying you're woke so woke I mean I
still shout at the ladies check this out
hey you hey you yeah you
you are not an object you are a human
being and I respect your right not to be
our gold all right gotta say that's yeah
I'm telling you I am so woke okay oh
hello there hello
yeah you
that's right I'll tell you something you
are not defined by your gender but by
your own human agency know what I'm
talking about I value you and respect
you as an equal
yeah that was very good I'm telling you
something Conan it is not easy
believe me right below the surface some
things work that was creepy yeah we
don't need to go into that oh man look
lady oh yeah let me tell you something I
do not have access to your sexuality
just because I can see you with my eyes
I respect your personal space and I
endeavoured to narrow the gap between us
created by a ruling patriarchy that
believes you should have a lower salary
and less rights that was great though
you shouldn't keep yelling woke but I am
proud of you whoa okay let's move on hey
Conan Conan at yellow I just wanted to
add one more thing what's that you got a
real pretty mouth hey what you got we're
gonna move along now you're a toad drink
of water Oh Brian I want to start at
your toes and take a week to get to your
pretty little nose all right that's
enough
who prevents t everybody thank you
[Applause]
you